How does life come from randomness? We imagine
the surface of the Earth billions of years
ago was random molten lava. But life is subtle
and complex and requires a lot of structure.
How could it be that structure could form
from randomness? If the system you’re looking
at is isolated, eventually that system will
randomize up to the extent that there's no
interesting structure. It will maximize entropy,
or disorder. So, you wouldn’t expect to
see anything. That’s because if any structure
tried to form, the random motion of the molecules
would knock apart whatever starts. However,
if you have some other source of energy that
keeps the system out of equilibrium – again,
the surface of the Earth, but now the Sun
is beating down on it – that extra source
of energy could smash things together and
create structures. Structures that are solid
enough that the little random motions of the
background pieces never disrupt it, or at
least don’t have enough time to. And the
structures could grow and grow. That’s a
nice little cartoon story, but is it true?
Well, recently there have been breakthroughs
in understanding what’s called non-equilibrium
processes. And proposals to explain how structure
can come from these seemingly random systems.
Those structures could be anything, but of
course one of the most exciting would be:
Could it be life – RNA molecules and everything
that comes after that. They’re delicate
little beings and you might worry that, put
in a little soup, the random motion would
destroy them. But perhaps they’re not so
delicate. And perhaps they’re even a predictive
consequence of a random Earth but with energy
imposed into the system. That is something
we can’t answer now, but is an exciting
new vein or way of people are thinking about
the problem and hope to solve it.